right
we're going to take you live to the u.s
white house president joe biden's
speaking now it's likely he's going to
be talking about a possible ban on
russian oil imports this is a move that
has strong bipartisan support the
congress and i believe in the country
americans have rallied support have
rallied to support the ukrainian people
and made it clear we will not be part of
subsidizing putin's war
this made we made this decision in close
consultation with our allies and our
partners around the world particularly
in europe
because a united response to putin's
aggression has been my overriding focus
to keep
all
nato and all of the eu and our allies
totally united
we're moving forward this ban
understanding that many of our european
allies and partners may not be in a
position to join us
the united states produces far more oil
domestically than all of europe and all
the european countries combined
in fact we're a net exporter of energy
so we can take this step when others
cannot
but we're working closely with europe
and our partners to develop a long-term
strategy to reduce their dependence on
russian energy as well
our teams are actively discussing how to
make this happen and today
we remain united we reign united in our
purpose to keep pressure mounting on
putin and his war machine
this is a step that we're taking to
inflict further pain on putin
but there will be cost as well here in
the united states i said i would level
with the american people from the
beginning
and when i first spoke to this i said
defending freedom is going to cost it's
going to cost us as well in the united
states republicans and democrats
understand alike understand that
republicans and democrats alike have
been clear that we must do this
over the last week i spoke with
president zielinski several times to
hear from him about the situation on the
ground and to consult
and continue to consult with
our european allies and about u.s
support for ukraine and the ukrainian
people
thus far we've provided more than one
billion dollars in security assistance
to ukraine
shipments of defensive weapons are
arriving ukraine every day from the
united states and we the united states
are the ones coordinating the delivery
of our allies and partners of similar
weapons from germany to finland to the
netherlands we're a com we're we're
working that out
we're also providing humanitarian
support for the ukrainian people
both those still in ukraine and those
who have fled safely to a neighboring
country
we're working with humanitarian
organizations to surge tens of thousands
of tons of food water and medical
supplies into ukraine and with more on
the way
over the weekend i sent secretary
blinken to visit
our border between the border between
poland and ukraine and to moldova
to see what the situation was firsthand
and report back
general milley chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff of our defense
department is also what was also in
europe meeting with his counterparts and
allies on nato's eastern flank to
reassure them those countries bordering
russia nato countries that we will keep
our nato commitment a sacred commitment
article of article 5.
the vice president harris is going to be
traveling to meet with our allies in
poland and romania later this week as
well
i've made it clear the united states
will share in the responsibility of
caring for the refugees so the costs do
not fall entirely on the european
country's border in ukraine
and yesterday i spoke with my
counterparts in france germany and the
united kingdom about russia's escalating
violence against ukraine and the steps
that we're going to take together with
our allies and partners around the world
to respond to this aggression
we are enforcing the most significant
package of economic sanctions in history
and it's causing significant damage to
russia's economy
it has caused russian economy to fight
frank crankly crater
the russian ruble is now down to 50
by 50 since putin's announced his war
one ruble
is now worth less than one american
penny
one ruble less than one american penny
and preventing russia's central bank
from propping up the ruble and to keep
its value up they're not going to be
able to do that now
we cut russia's largest banks from the
international financial system and has
crippled their ability to do business
with the rest of the world
in addition we're choking off russia's
access to technology like semiconductors
that are and uh and sap it's uh its
economic strength and weakened its
military for years to come
major companies are pulling out of
russia entirely without even being asked
not by us over the weekend visa
mastercard american express they all
suspended their services in russia all
of them
joining a growing list of american and
global companies from
ford to nike to apple they've suspended
their operations in russia
the u.s stock exchange has hauled a
trading of many russian securities
the private sector is united against
russia's vicious war of choice
the u.s department of justice has
assembled a dedicated task force to go
after
russian for the crimes of russian
oligarchs and we're joining with our
european allies to find and seize their
yachts their luxury apartments their
private jets and all their ill-begotten
gains to make sure that they share in
the pain of putin's war
these by the way are giant yachts you
put some of them in your press i mean
some of them are i think i've read one
was over 400 feet long i mean
it's uh this is worth hundreds of
millions of dollars
the decision today is not without cost
here at home
putin's war is already hurting american
families at the gas pump
since putin began his military buildup
on ukrainian borders just since then
the price of the gas at the pump in
america went up 75 cents
and with this action it's going to go up
further
i'm going to do everything i can to
minimize putin's price hike here at home
in coordination with our partners we've
already announced that we're releasing
60 million barrels
of oil from our joint oil reserves half
of that 30 billion
million excuse me is coming from the
united states
and we're taking steps to ensure the
reliable supply of global energy
are also going to keep working
with every tool at our disposal protect
american families and businesses
now
let me let me say this
to the oil and gas companies to the
finance firms that pack them
we understand putin's war against the
people of ukraine is causing prices to
rise we get that that's self-evident but
but but but
it's no excuse to exercise excessive
price increases or padding profits or
any kind of effort to exploit this
situation
or amer or american consumers exploit
them
russia's aggression is costing us all
and it's no time for profiteering or
price gouging i want to be clear about
what we'll not tolerate
but i also want to acknowledge those
firms and oil and gas industries that
are pulling out of russia and joining
other businesses that are leading by
example
this is a time when we have to do our
part
and make sure we're not taking we're not
taking advantage look let me be clear
about two other points first
it's simply not true that my
administration or policies are holding
back domestic energy production
that's simply not true
even amid the pandemic companies in the
united states pump more oil during my
first year in office than they did
during my predecessor first year
we're approaching a record levels of oil
and gas production in the united states
and we're on track to set a record of
oil production next year
in the united states
90
of onshore oil production takes place on
land that isn't owned by the federal
government
and of the remaining 10 percent that
occurs on federal land the oil and gas
industry has millions of acres leased
they have 9 000 permits to drill now
they could be drilling right now
yesterday last week last year
they have 9 000
to drill on shore that are already
approved
so let me be clear let me be clear they
are not using them for production now
that's their decision these are the
facts
we should be honest about the facts
second
this crisis is a stark reminder to
protect our economy over the long term
we need to become energy independent
i've had numerous conversations over the
last three months with our european
friends of how they have to wean
themselves off of us russian oil it's
just not
it's just not tenable
it should motivate us to accelerate the
transition of clean energy
this is a perspective extended our
european allies share
and the future where together we can
achieve greater independence
loosening environmental regulations are
pulling back clean energy investment
won't let me explain won't will not
lower energy prices for families
but transforming our economy to run on
electric vehicles powered by clean
energy with tax credits to help american
families winterize their homes and use
less energy that will that will help
and if we can if we do we can it will
mean that no one has to worry about
price of gas pump in the future
that'll mean tyrants like putin won't be
able to use fossil fuels as weapons
against other nations
and it will make america a world leader
manufacturing and exporting clean energy
technology of the future to countries
all around the world this is the goal we
should be racing toward
over the last two weeks ukrainian people
have inspired the world and i mean that
in a literal sense they've inspired the
world with their bravery their
patriotism their defiant determination
to live free
putin's war putin's war has caused
enormous suffering and needless loss of
life
of women children everyone in ukraine
both ukraine and i might add russians
ukrainian leaders as well as leaders
around the world have repeatedly called
for a ceasefire
for humanitarian relief
for real diplomacy but putin seems
determined to continue on his murderous
path no matter the cost
putin's now targeting cities and has
been targeting cities in civilian
schools hospitals apartment buildings
last week he attacked the largest
nuclear power plant in europe with an
apparent disregard for the potential of
triggering a nuclear meltdown
he has already
turned 2 million ukrainians into
refugees
russia may continue to grind out its
advance at a horrible price
but this much is already clear
ukraine will never be a victory for
putin
putin may be able to take a city
but he'll never be able to hold the
country
and if we do not respond to putin's
assault on global
peace and stability today the cost of
freedom and to the american people will
be even greater tomorrow
so we're going to continue to support
the brave ukrainian people as they fight
for their country and i call on congress
to pass the 12 billion ukraine
assistance package that i have asked
them for of late
ukrainian people are demonstrating by
their physical courage that they are not
about to just let putin take what he
wants
that's clear
they'll defend their freedom
their democracy
their lives and we're going to keep
providing security assistance economic
assistance and humanitarian assistance
we're going to support them against
tyranny oppression violent acts of
subjugation
people everywhere and i i think it's
maybe even surprised some of you all
people everywhere are speaking up for
freedom
when the history of this war is written
putin's war on ukraine will have left
russia weaker
and the rest of the world's stronger
and god bless all those heroes in
ukraine and now i'm off to texas thank
you very very much i know there's a lot
of questions
i know
i know there's a lot of
questions but there's a lot more that
has to be made clear and i'm going to
hold on that until we get more
information thank you appreciate it
you're watching al jazeera we've been
bringing you live pictures from the u.s
white house where president joe biden
has been speaking
and confirming that the united states is
willing to move ahead with a ban on
russian oil imports without the
participation of allies in europe he was
talking also about the humanitarian aid
that the americans that the u.s had been
supplying to ukraine as well as the
military
support he did say that he had said
right at the start that this defending
uh freedom he said
was going to cost and of course that has
been reflected in the prices of fuel
that we have seen at uh american fuel
pumps as well as other parts of the
world i want to bring in kimberly
hawking he's she's our white house
correspondent um perhaps kimberly in
many ways no surprise but definitely the
u.s prepared to go it alone in this
instance
yeah but it's easier for the united
states to go it alone uh and you heard
the u.s president acknowledging that and
i'll sort of explain why when you look
at how much
the united states imports in terms of
russian oil it's about 700 000 barrels a
day that's about 10 percent of the
nation's energy supply contrasts that
with europe where they are importing
about 4 million
barrels a day
and you realize why there might be some
european nations that are somewhat more
reticent to put in place this oil
embargo russian oil embargo in contrast
to the united states now still the the
white house was slow to put this one in
place and uh you heard there the u.s
president saying that it was something
that he spoke about with the ukrainian
leader vladimir zelinski on multiple
locations in fact we know that he in
fact pled with the u.s president to put
this in place because there would be a
punishing impact on the russian economy
and this is something that the
u.s president although he put in place a
number of economic sanctions did not put
this one in place until uh we saw a
series of sanctions go into effect and
the reason is because of the impact to
the u.s consumer and you heard the u.s
president acknowledging that there's
going to be pain at the gas pump for the
american consumer right now uh us
consumers on average are paying about
four dollars plus for a gallon of
gasoline or petrol that's up from about
two dollars and seventy cents a year ago
but that is expected to climb
significantly you heard there the u.s
president saying that this could go up
by at least 75 cents a gallon that's a
lot for an american given the fact that
uh right now americans are paying for
ordinary consumer goods some of the
highest prices they've seen in terms of
inflation uh given the fact that
inflation is the highest we've seen in
about 40 years so this could come at a
price for the us president politically
uh still this is something that the u.s
president underscored in his remarks
that he believes is worthy of doing
because in his
argument
what the point he's trying to make is
this is all about freedom and the
message has to be sent to the russian
president that look you could take a
city but you're not going to hold the
country and these are about american
values and standing up for american
values and those are worth defending and
and that is why the u.s president
believes this is something that
he is
willing to do and he's made the case to
the american public so
whether or not the american public is
going to be on board is still unclear i
guess we might even have to wait till
the november congressional elections for
that but we should point out that the
u.s president made the argument that
both democrats and republicans on
capitol hill are behind this in fact
they had their own legislation going
to put in place sanctions on russian
energy so uh it appears that on the
heels of that effort by congress the
white house has gone ahead and done
their own
i'm saying that the u.s house majority
leader sidney hoyer is quoted as saying
that lawmakers are apparently discussing
ways to ease the impact on prices of
russian of a russian energy ban that's
going to be key in the u.s isn't it
because as you said the us's
exposure if you like to the russian oil
energy market is fairly limited but
americans are still feeling the pinch of
that trying to find ways of alleviating
it balancing out those high prices at
the pumps is going to be key to the
administration
yeah and we did hear from the chair of
the federal reserve jerome powell in uh
the last week or so and he did discuss
that there are some things that can be
done to mitigate that one of them is
raising interest rates but it is a
delicate dance in terms of trying to
ease some of this pressure and there's
only so much that you can do and so uh
we're going to watch to see what is
going to be done but the bottom line in
all of this is that american consumers
are going to be paying higher prices for
gasoline and in some ways that's not
entirely a bad thing in the eyes of the
biden administration there is this
argument that there is this feeling that
too many americans are driving there is
this feeling that they want to see more
people purchasing electric vehicles the
problem is is that the infrastructure
isn't in place for a lot of these
electric vehicles just yet and also the
wages haven't kept up with inflation in
the united states so the goals are
ambitious
but the problem is is the infrastructure
isn't quite there to support some of
those ambitious goals that's going to be
the problem for congress to sort out
it's going to take some time and it's
probably going to be messy in the
interim kimberly thank you very much
indeed white house correspondent
kimberly hawkert in washington dc let's
bring our diplomatic editor james bazin
he's joining us from paris um the point
being made there of course that the
blinkin administration is quite clearly
aware that they're going to have to go
with this uh themselves because in
europe and in the uk and on other allies
there is a certain reticence to making
such a dramatic move
yeah there is i'll come to the uk in a
moment because we have some news on the
uk that's just come in but yes the eu
would find it very hard to do this the
27 countries of the eu 30 of their
energy comes from russia so it would and
and we're still pretty cold temperatures
in some parts of europe so you'd have
the effect on consumers you'd then also
have the effect on businesses this could
already president biden's talking about
the hurt that they'll be for americans
uh but clearly there's a danger if you
were to do this in the european
countries of pushing the world further
towards recession that's the situation
in many european countries of course the
uk no longer part of the 27 member eu
um and in the last few minutes
quasi-cuatang who is the business
secretary in prime minister johnson's
government has tweeted that the uk is
going to follow the us by the end of
2022 they'll phase out the import of
russian oil and oil products by the end
of the year says those imports make up 8
of uk demand so far less uh than is is
in the eu and the eu countries uh with
regard to gas uh he says he's coming up
with a plan but he wants to end import
of gas as well so the uk it seems is
signaling that it's going to do
something similar but it's very hard i
think for many of the european union
countries and particularly
for germany
to follow with this now although we've
heard from
senior european leaders um just speaking
again on on twitter in the last couple
of hours of the wanderline who is the
president of the european commission
saying it's something that europe is
going to have to do it was going to have
to do anyway changing its energy
supplies because of the environment to
go more green it's now going to have to
speed up that process and throughout all
of this uh president uh putin has
forgive me president uh lincoln has been
um
i'm sorry u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken has been having meetings with
french president emmanuel macron we
understand the talks are still going on
france of course being one of the
biggest economies
in the european uh union just talk us
around what that what is happening there
well i think this is part of the
very constant diplomacy that's going on
to keep everyone in the loop and that's
why the u.s secretary of state has been
on a tour he went to those countries uh
closest to ukraine that are taking in
refugees he's then been to the baltic
countries those that are near russia and
fear russia those that are eu members
and nato
members mr blinken is now with his
french
counterpart john eve la drill and he
will be seeing in about 15 minutes time
president macron for a courtesy visit to
him to keep in the loop of what the
french are doing and the french of
course and the germans have been doing
quite a lot um president macron in
recent days has talked to president
putin that was a very negative
conversation they talked for a long time
and there was told we were told by
officials nothing very positive came out
of it perhaps more interesting for the
u.s secretary of state will be his news
on what we've been told about was
another uh recent call this was a video
conference between the german chancellor
olaf schoff schultz
and president macron and president xi of
china china because it has a
partnerships with russia
and is is certainly not taking sides in
this in the same way
that the nato and eu countries are it's
very much seen by mostly most observers
to be more on russia's side so china
because of that has real influence and i
think we're not being told a lot about
what was said other other than they're
trying to work particularly on the
humanitarian front and working towards a
ceasefire but what was what would be
told and briefed to the u.s secretary of
state privately perhaps will give us
more uh or give them more on the
situation behind the scenes the chinese
position and china is a country that has
real leverage here
and so double diplomatic editor james
braise bringing us bringing up to date
with the movements of u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken and the talks that
he's been having james thank you very
much indeed i want to go to gabriel
elizondo he's live for us in new york um
gabriel just talk us through what kind
of response this
oil ban may produce because it has been
expected hasn't it
it has been but certainly this was an
announcement about oil an unprecedented
announcement quite frankly
about the u.s limiting imports of
russian oil and it is going to have an
immediate effect on the oil markets
we've already seen brent crude which is
the
the benchmark if you will already reach
about a hundred and thirty nine dollars
sunday
into monday uh the highest
price for a barrel of bent brent crude
since 2008
right now it's come down a little bit to
about a dollar
30 a 27.30 but that's still very high
now the question is going to become what
are we going to see it going to in the
coming hours and days and according to
most analysts here on wall street they
were predicting
around 140 550
now we've got jp morgan based on this uh
new information predicting that by the
end of 2022 the end of this year we
could see brent crude reaching up to 185
dollars a barrel again that's going to
have direct impact impacts on consumers
around the world
now biden announced there and that what
he announced previously that the u.s
would be releasing with about 30 allies
about 60 million barrels out of the
strategic reserves biden is announcing
that because he wants to calm the
markets a little bit but here on wall
street it's not going to do that and
that's because 60 million barrels uh
released from their strategic reserves
is quite frankly nothing the world
consumes per day
about a hundred billion million with an
m uh barrels of oil a day so the 60
million just simply will not be enough
to calm the markets and bring down the
prices yeah and uh president biden in
his speech there was referring to the
fact that many um as he described it
private or international companies have
been pulling out credit card companies
but also the shell energy company
general electric both speaking today
what kind of impact is that having on
the markets generally
as biden was speaking the dow jones
industrial average was in the green i
was about 200 points in the green
meaning in positive territory
as biden was speaking it went into the
red and now dow jones industrial average
the s p 500 nasdaq are all now
completely in the red
the market is getting hit very hard
biden was talking about how how these
sanctions were affecting the russian
economy
people have been predicting how it would
spread to the global economy and now
that is exactly what we have been seeing
and that is now more of what we are
going to be seeing uh the s p 500 has
its worst day uh since october of 2020
on yesterday on monday the dow fell 800
points on monday and the nasdaq dropped
almost 4 percent on monday as well off
20 from its november high the big
picture here is this it's complicated
but it's not just oil it's not just the
markets it's multiple things it's the
sanctions
it's uh the supply chain issues that we
continue to have globally inflation
concerns inflation the highest rate that
it's been in the us for over a decade
and commodity prices going up as well
hanging over all of this of course is
the war and now uh the oil sanctions as
one uh uh oil uh limited of oil coming
into the u.s add all of this up now and
that's why you have wall street and the
markets around the world really reacting
the way they are reacting very much
going into the red as one trader said
this is very much not just one issue
we're dealing with it's really a perfect
storm of four five now maybe even six
issues all coalescing at one time
gabriel thank you very much indeed
gabriel elizondo bringing us up to date
with what's going on in the markets live
for us in new york